it's sound like a part 1 what does it
ask what's the probability that a
particular student chose neither
extension amounts nor extension one
English so we look at the situations
where when not in these circles right
before we get to the actual probability
how do I write this how do I describe
someone using the language of notation
I've got here who doesn't do extension
maths doesn't do extension weren't
English exactly why you're here hmm
let's contemplate this idea compliment
of a copy of firstly what did we agree
that they mean that's okay that's right
I want to I want to consider this is the
important part right what what is this
area cultivate it's everyone outside of
the outside of this circle do you agree
that yep okay so we know where that area
is and then this is everyone outside of
the M circle right in fact what I'd like
you do maybe without worrying about the
numbers but just maybe on the side of
this right could you take what Zack is
just suggested and shade on to here's
our new diagram don't worry about the
numbers we're gonna call this a I'm
gonna call this M could you shade for me
where do you think this particular set
belongs and then that will not just
answer the question of yes or no but
tell us why okay I'll give you a second
drew yourself up just a quick and oh
don't don't put the numbers back on
because we're just gonna color straight
over them where is the union of outside
a and outside out just to have a think
for a second the Union
good good okay so let me help you out
right I'll do one at a time okay and by
the way people in who have come from
this is--these in AI class know this but
those of you who were not maybe don't
colors colors are really helpful they
communicate a lot of things unless
you're colorblind but if you are not
colorblind which is most of you use
colors to your advantage for instance
right let's do this
not a means everyone outside of e so
there's the e circle so I'm gonna shade
in green that's not a you okay with that
did I did I cover it yep okay so that's
not eight now I'm gonna do not M so
that's this circle out yeah don't want
to go inside that when you go there we
go like so are you okay with that my red
has gone everywhere except for inside
that circle of M right
it's another Union what is Union mean we
looked at intersection this morning what
is Union me there's a word that goes
with Union right it's this or that right
either one is fine so anywhere inside my
terribly colored diagram so long as
there's some color on it we would
include that in this set is this the set
that we want it's actually not right
what we want is not in this circle
instead of or we want and not in this
circle right we want the outside stuff
right so the way I would say that is
let's see figure out this what will we
put in two set right
so what this means is not just if
there's a color that's fine I want both
colors to be there now just have a look
closely right you see this little sort
of Crescent in here there's only a
single color there do you're great it's
only red okay so I'm like that's that's
out that's not gonna count I need both
colors to be involved and then there's
this section right in here which is only
green do you see that and I need both
colors so I'm also going to
school in that so really I'm getting
this region on the outside now you can
tell me what the number is 42 thank you
very much so there's my favorable
outcomes but then we also need and this
is why we filled in the totals over
there
we need our sample space what's the
sample space 193 very good it's everyone
done that's it okay so at the moment is
this conditional probability not not
really yet because we didn't have the
key they'll tell you because unlike when
I give you a heading and say there's a
conditional probability right when you
encounter a question the key phrase that
will tell you this is conditional
probability is look at part two it says
extension one English where's the word
given that right or you might also see
if it is no right any of these things
tell you there's a condition involved so
now let's think about this probability
extension one English given that they
chose extension 1 maths so the thing
that I'm interested in is extension 1
English that's how I'm indicating at the
moment what was the symbol we introduced
this morning to say given that do you
realize yeah it's just the pipe that one
vertical line right like so okay and
what's the condition that I know given
that look at the question it's there
they chose extension 1 maths right very
good
all right that's what I've got now
hopefully you got written down early
this morning we actually have a formula
for this right so I'm gonna write the
formula down we'll get the numbers and
then we'll interpret it okay if I
remember right what we say is it's still
a fraction right we change the sample
space right the sample space is
diminished now instead of being the
number of everything 193 it's just the
number of the given condition right
that's the thing you know to be sure so
I'm gonna write like that okay and then
I say on the top this is my favorable
votes right this also changes do you
remember what we had up here what was in
here
we used this intersection symbol yeah it
didn't wait right it's actually it's
really nice this is one of the good
things if you use this format
it's everything that was written here in
exactly the same order okay so it's
gonna be e intersect M like so right
these
those particular English students we're
forgetting about the English students
that don't do maths because we know
that's forgiven condition alright let's
have a look a intersect em where's that
on my diagram it's the 29 it's the
overlap
isn't it so I'm gonna write that right
at the top 29 over and then I've got the
number of people in this circle which
handily I have already calculated where
is it mmm it's here isn't it yeah there
we go I've already got this number 124
and we're done I even know I can't
simplify because 29 is prime okay are
you happy with that you see how we
calculated it and you see what it means
over there can I ask you to have a go up
at 3:00 and putt for without my help
first if you've got a question does it
my own questions yeah why is it the 124
okay let's think about this you came a
little bit later so you guys are going
to help me right why is it that we
change the sample space and not have it
over 193 why do we do that is it
constrains chase did you want to run
into something very good in fact that's
a really good way to summarize right
because you know more you could exclude
you can cut out some of these options
right because you know that the person
you're randomly selected is doing maths
right have a look on this diagram for a
second which numbers can i erase I can
raise with definitely here right because
I'm interested in the field in our maths
I can also raise these guys right it's
not gonna be one of these guys it's
outside the math circle so I can pretend
they don't exist this is my new sample
space does this make sense so that's why
I've changed the denominator okay times
I question
what's the owner 100k so you've written
x has written something a bit
differently you've written I think you
said a union okay so I'd like all of us
to consider this for a second can you
have a look at this with me
we're using our our new set notation and
also our complement notation okay does
this work how does this question is why
can't I do this right
what is a union err what does it look
like hmm
don't you describe it to someone if you
were telling me to shade some stuff what
would I shade everything hold on a
second
look before we get to the component just
just e Union M anything that's an e ya
Union is or isn't it this is the problem
we encountered at the beginning right
let me show you a union M goes all the
way through both of our circles right
anyone in here the Union I'll just
combined them and put them together okay
now what does that bar over the top now
mean yeah everything that's the opposite
of that does that describe if I take the
part that's why right now does that
describe the same as this
it looks like my diagram is that bad oh
yeah yes it does
they are the same right this white area
and this multicolored area red and green
they are the same it's just the stuff
outside the circle so the shortest your
question is totally fine just another
way I think you had the same region okay